When I was a boy, I had to choose paths.
Or fate would choose for me.
I've hurt people
and I'm going to hurt more.
I'm asking forgiveness for what I'm about to do.
savages
Gang war.
The city
crumbles.
Nothing about
this brings me joy
You brought this on yourself
It hurts me
I have to kill you
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Marvel has been releasing a bunch of daredevil
Netflix defenders footage and trailers
the past couple of weeks, revealing
that it's canonized all the Netflix stuff to the MCU.
Really happy to see them finally acknowledge that in
now because they're bringing back all these
defenders characters we have daredevil born again
happening the been a couple of teasers for that so far,
especially with the ending of the Echo series
in that Post-Credits scene.
A lot of you have been asking
if they're going to bring Bullseye back too,
because there was a big teaser at the end of Daredevil
season three and now all that stuff is Kiernan
the original showrunner for Daredevil Season
three also revealed some of their plans
for Daredevil Season four.
So we'll break it all down because technically,
all that stuff is now canon to the MCU confirmed.
I know there's a bunch of questions about when
all the Defenders characters are actually coming back,
like when and how are they coming back
and is it going to be during Daredevil Born Again?
Are they going to wait till a little bit later?
Are there going to be other spinoff series like will
they do more series
based on the Defenders characters again in the MCU?
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Of course, I will do videos for whatever series,
whatever episodes they wind up releasing,
whoever winds up coming back.
but the important stuff first like basic idea
is that daredevil born again is essentially
marvel reworking what would have been Daredevil season
four in the Netflix series.
But in the MCU proper this time.
now they have completely changed the story
that they would have originally done
in Daredevil Season four.
But essentially
it's like a new version of season four.
They're just calling it Daredevil Born Again,
which is funny because they actually use the Daredevil
Born Again comic book like the Frank Miller comic book
for the events of Daredevil Season three.
The Circle of Easter Eggs is now complete.
We see what you're doing there.
Kevin FYI, they're couple legal reasons
and production reasons why Disney and Marvel changed
the title of Daredevil Born Again from Daredevil Season
four Instead of just calling it Season four. but.
Thankfully the showrunner did reveal
what was going to happen during Daredevil season four.
So originally they ended on that bullseye end credits
scene where he's getting his brand new spine
a lot of you've been
asking now is he coming back
like everyone else in Daredevil Born Again?
The original story for Daredevil Season
four would have featured Bullseye coming back
A virgin of the owl coming back from previous seasons
in paying off Melvin Potter's
Gladiator storyline and Typhoid
Mary crossing over from Iron fist season two.
So there would have been a little bit of defenders
crossover during season four, as you would expect
Wilson
but those bullseye would have become a more comic book
accurate version of Bullseye
getting his titanium spine.
But because we're talking about MCU here,
they're introducing Adamantium during Captain America
four Brave New World. It's
going to be part of that team.
It's celestial that's in the Indian Ocean right now.
there explaining the MCU.
That's where adamantium comes from.
Like literally it just grew on his body.
that's meant to set up what's happening
with MCU Wolverine down the line, like after Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine comes back in Deadpool three
and you have weapons plus Weapon X,
all that kind of stuff,
just sort of laying the track work for that. but
because they're doing that now they can actually make
bullseye spine adamantium like it is in the comics.
there are a lot of questions about that.
When Daredevil Season three came out
because this was in 2018, back
before Avengers Infinity War and the snap happened,
like, is it going to be Adamantium?
Are they going to produce Adamantium
among all these Marvel Netflix series?
but he would have come back for revenge against
Daredevil and Kingpin because Kingpin technically
is the one that broke his spine
if you remember Leland Owsley,
the accountant from Daredevil Season
one that was killed by Kingpin
after he learned Owsley tried to have
Vanessa killed, thinking that she was distracting
Kingpin from there, undertaking
that whole mission to dig up the dragon bones
that they paid off in the Defender series.
Eventually, Owsley Sun would have come back
using his assets
to get revenge against Kingpin in Daredevil
and become a more comic book version of The Owl.
But here's the thing.
In the comics, the owl actually has biological powers,
like bird based powers, basically.
they're a bunch of experiments.
He takes a bunch of serum just enhancing his abilities.
He uses the vulture and other villains as his henchmen.
this is the showrunners of Daredevil Season
two in Daredevil.
Season three talking to each other
about Daredevil, Season four characters.
but I think
because everything they were doing
with the Daredevil Netflix series and just in general,
the Defender series, everything was meant to be
so street level, real world inspired.
they probably wouldn't have given him
his full biological powers other than maybe enhanced
regeneration senses, speed, strength,
like very low level powers
that would have put him on par with some of the other
defenders characters, the showrunner said that
they intended to finish Melvin Potter's storyline,
that they'd tease through the first couple of seasons.
He would have finished becoming The Gladiator
or character from the comics.
Now, in the comics,
he went insane and becomes a much bigger villain.
but on the show, they kind of addressed this
by saying that he had a disability
and kingpin had just been taking advantage of him,
threatened to kill his girlfriend Betty Daredevil
eventually helps him and he makes daredevil's suits.
but it sounds like he would have been threatened again
by the villains in season four
and that would have caused him
to turn into full gladiator from the comics.
Maybe gone off the rails until Daredevil
eventually helped him again.
Maybe he would have wound up in an asylum
like he did in the comics.
Unless you think he would have gotten a happy ending.
Depends on how happy you think
all these shows wind up ending four?
Those asking what happened to Kingpin in all of this?
Because remember, this is still coming off
the ending of Daredevil season three
and they kind of addressed what happened to him
during the five year time jump on the Echoes series.
It sounds like for the duration of Daredevil
season four, that would have happened
during the five year time jump
in at least when season four is happening,
like in the early part of the five year
time, jump Kingpin still would have been in jail
for the events of season four, something similar
to what you saw from him during Daredevil Season two,
where he was still trying to hold his empire together
from inside prison.
But he was largely stuck in prison.
basically explained at the end of season three
that Kingpin was going to leave all them alone.
Like Daredevil was not worried about Kingpin
coming to bother them as long
as Vanessa stayed free and they didn't go after her.
So I think the idea is that if season four
is taking place, like right at the beginning
of the five year time, jump Kingpin
isn't like a really huge character during the season.
Like he just cameos a couple of times just to explain
what he's been doing, why he's in prison.
the whole thing.
With his character on Echo, though,
they explain at some point during the five year time
jump, he eventually got out of prison.
A lot of people wondering how this happened
because it doesn't seem like
he's stayed in there for a long time.
I think the best theory right now
is that all the really important people that Daredevil
was using to testify against him in court,
like all the people
the city were using to prosecute him,
essentially got snapped.
So their cases fell apart
like Daredevil's case against kingpin fell apart.
therefore they probably had to release him.
And that's how Kingpin is walking around
during the five year time jump.
Because you see him, you're just walking
through the police in there terrified of him,
let him do pretty much whatever he wants to do
one of the other major villains, though,
sounds like it was going to be Typhoid Mary.
in Remember, at the end of Iron Fist,
she had started working for Joy Meachum,
sort of as her hired muscle,
although they implied that she was pushing Joy around
and she was kind of the leader in their relationship
there was this whole arc with Joy Meachum
where they kind of teased her going dark,
but she's not like full blown villain yet.
Like she's not for Kingpin yet, Charlie Cox also said
that Daredevil would have repaired his relationship
with Karen Page and he considers her
to be the best girl for Daredevil in the MCU.
Like everybody's always wondering, like,
who is his main girl?
Technically, the way Charlie Cox sees it, it's meant
to be Karen Page lot of people asking about Elektra.
It's always possible she comes back too.
I don't think she's meant to come back
during Daredevil Born again Season one, though. but.
He would have also repaired his relationship
with Foggy Nelson.
They basically pay off the teaser
from the end of season
three with them forming the new law firm
Murdock, Nelson in page.
But by this time, Foggy and Karen become more involved
with his activities as Daredevil
by Night, basically being more in on his activities
as a superhero.
like he wasn't going to continue
sneaking around behind their backs fighting crime.
And because they have all the other Netflix defenders
series, remember, this is when they were originally
planning on continuing all those series,
you would have seen more crossover
from the other characters like Jessica Jones, Luke Cage
obviously already mentioned all the Iron Fist crossover
with Daredevil Season four, Punisher
would have also come back because they're all operating
in the New York City area for the most part.
they didn't really say what their plans were
for Defenders season two
because they canceled the plans for that
pretty early on, like after Defenders Season one aired.
I don't think it landed
the way that Netflix wanted it to,
so they didn't want to pay
for another season of the Defenders team up.
the funny thing about Marvel canonizing
all the Marvel Netflix stuff to the MCU
is that Vincent D'Onofrio revealed
that actually was a relatively recent thing
that they all had a big meeting about
when they actually decided
to reboot Daredevil Born Again,
like there was an original version.
Kevin Foggy saw what they were shooting.
They canceled that in hired the Punisher showrunner,
the Loki writers to redo Daredevil born again in.
They're getting ready to start doing that right now
but last year during the strike
when they elected to do that
that's when they had their big meeting
and decided to canonize everything to the MCU.
Like it wasn't until just last year
when this all happened.
but part of the plan is the date of a born again
is just the beginning of that on this street level.
New York City area,
I've already done a couple of videos about Punisher
and everybody else that's supposed to come back
during Daredevil Born again season one.
But let me know which other characters you want to see.
Come back next.
I just did a big video for the Daredevil Born again
teaser in the Echo Post-Credits scene.
Click here to watch that and click here
to learn about Iron Fist
also coming back
and which version of Iron Fist it's going to be.
Thank you so much for watching.
And I'll see you guys in the next one!